depuis 12 ans pas moins de vingt-cinq
mille passionnés d'histoire se
rassemblent à versailles le dernier
week-end de novembre cette année
confinement oblige la 13e édition du
salon histoire de lire se fera en
visioconférence c'est pas parce que nous
sommes confinés voire même au contraire
c'est parce que nous sommes confinés
nous avons plus de temps libre pour pour
lire
voilà mais faut-il encore avoir accès
aux livres
donc voilà on facilite ce travail avec
ce salon hors du commun
au programme des live tous les soirs
pendant quinze jours avec les auteurs
invités du salon les visiteurs virtuels
pourront poser leurs questions en direct
sur youtube ou facebook
on attaque avec le général gomart qui va
nous raconter l'histoire des services
secrets
on enchaîne avec muriel gilbert qui va
nous parler de l'histoire de l'eau
française aura parlé de de gaulle mais
aussi patrick poivre d'arvor alain juppé
ou encore raphaëlle bacqué les auteurs
seront nombreux pas de rencontre
physique mais les organisateurs ont
souhaité conserver la partie dédicaces
vous envoyez un message pendant le
direct et donc les auteurs que nous
recevons dans le studio télé resteront
une heure après pour signer tous les
livres qui auraient été commandés et
tous ces livres seront click and collect
chez les libraires notamment la rivière
antoine de versailles
un apéro d'auteur pour remplacer les
traditionnels cafés est aussi prévue
enfin autre événement de cette 13e
édition le prix du youtube heures
d'histoire mise en place il y a trois
ans à la place de la grande cérémonie
avec 500 jeunes en live
là aussi il y a donc 34 jeunes youtuber
qui ont concouru cette année c'est un
record absolu qui en a huit nominés il
faudra choisir tranchées qui est le
youtube heures 2020 entièrement digital
ce rendez vous littéraire y finnois
durera 15 jours du 16 au 28 novembre
avis aux curieux confiné